in a previous video we started thinking
about strategies for dividing numbers
where either the numbers or decimals or
their quotients are going to be decimals
so now let's continue that we're going
to do slightly more involved examples so
let's say we want to figure out what 500
divided by 200 is divided by 200 pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out
well one strategy for doing this is to
just really Express this as a fraction
and see if you can simplify this
fraction in a way that it's
straightforward to express it as a
decimal so for example this is going to
be the same thing this is equal to five
hundred five hundred over two hundred
and now we can simplify this we could
say this is the same thing as five times
105 times 100 over two times 100 the
reason why that is useful if you say hey
look I have a hundred in the numerator I
have 100 in the denominator 100 divided
by 100 is just going to be one so you
could just view this this is equal to
five has five halves x times 100 over
100 times 100 over 100 which is just
going to be equal to which is just going
to be equal to one another way to think
about it you could divide the numerator
by 100 and you would have five and as
long as you divide the denominator by
the same thing you're not changing the
value of the fraction
so if you divide the denominator by 100
you're going to get two so anyway you
think about it this could be simplified
as five halves but we're not done yet
that is that is what 500 divided by 200
is but can we express this as a decimal
well we can rewrite five halves as a
mixed number so five halves is going to
be equal to well how many times was 2
going to five well it goes two times and
then you have one half left over so this
is going to be two and 1/2 and 1/2
and now how do we express this right
over here as a decimal
well you might recognize that 1/2 is the
same thing as 5/10 so this is going to
be equal to 2 and 5 over 10 which of
course we can write as 2 point 5 or 2
and 5 tenths so 500 divided by 200 is 2
point 5 let's do another example let's
say we wanted to figure out what 0.6 3
divided by divided by zero point zero 7
is pause this video and see if you can
come up with a strategy for doing this
well there's multiple ways to tackle it
one way is real is to think about both
of them in terms of hundreds so for
example this is 63 hundredths under its
and this right over here is seven
hundred hundreds and so if you have 63
of something and you're dividing that by
700 what are you going to get well
you're going to this if you took your
seven hundredths and you multiply it by
nine you're going to get 63 hundreds and
so 63 of something divided by seven of
that same something is going to be equal
to nine this is going to be equal this
is going to be equal to 9 7 times 9 is
63 so seven hundredths times nine is
going to be 63 hundredths another way to
think about it is we can express this as
a fraction so in the numerator you have
zero point six three and the denominator
you have zero point zero seven and if
the decimals are bothering us we can
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator by the same value to get rid
of the decimals so let's multiply the
numerator by 100 and also multiply the
denominator by a hundred this doesn't
change
value of the expression because
multiplying by 100 over 100 is just the
same thing as multiplying by 1 so this
would be equal to 63 hundredths times
100 well we would move the decimal two
to the right this is going to be equal
to 63 over seven hundredths times 100
once again we move the decimal two to
the right this is going to be seven so
63 divided by seven once again that is
going to be equal to that is going to be
equal to nine